so speaking of investigations for an
investigation that was never going to
exist the Trump Russia investigation is
seeming increasingly serious not only
did we learn in the last 24 hours that a
special prosecutor Robert Muller wants
to interview Donald Trump himself we've
also learned in the last 24 hours
that he did interview attorney general
Jeff Sessions the investigation has
officially informally reached Donald
Trump's cabinet attorney general Jeff
Sessions who has already been caught
lying at least twice during previous
testimony related to contact with
Russians was questioned for hours hours
on end by Robert molars team sessions is
ostensibly in charge of all law
enforcement in the United States and law
enforcement is interviewing him in a
criminal investigation and this took
place late last week but we just learned
about it this week and as far as we know
right now this is the first time that
Robert molars team has reached a Trump
cabinet member it's possible that others
have been interviewed and we just don't
know about it but it doesn't seem
particularly likely right now and there
are two blockbusters here okay
blockbuster number one is like I said an
investigation that we were told was
never going to be anything has reached
Donald Trump's cabinet and recalled that
Trump said it would end by Thanksgiving
it would end by Christmas it would end
by New Year's and it's 2018 and we're
only just starting the investigation
elements that involve Trump's cabinet
members this has a long way to go but
the bigger blockbuster in my mind is
that this connects with even more
possible obstruction of justice
Axios and others have reported that
recently Jeff Sessions has been
pressuring FBI director Christopher Rea
to fire the deputy FBI director Andrew
McCabe McCabe has done nothing to
warrant being fired but we can imagine
that his firing might help Trump in the
context of the Russia investigation and
in fact Trump has even publicly urged
sessions to fire McCabe
FBI director Christopher Rea reportedly
threatened to resign if McCabe was
removed according to three sources with
direct knowledge sessions and Trump
apparently had the good enough sense to
realize wait a second we fired FBI
director James Comey that led to a
special prosecutor being appointed it
probably would not be good in terms of
optics if now Andrew McCabe was fired at
our urging I I'm speculating but I guess
maybe they had the sense to realize that
this would not go over particularly no
yeah and the stems from McCabe being
pulled into an office meeting by Donald
Trump after Trump fired Comey because I
guess McCabe's wife ran for state Senate
in Virginia I believe I received a
campaign contribution from the former
Democratic governor of Virginia so Trump
pressured McCabe into telling him who he
voted for in 2016 and that's Ryan doubt
if he was a Democrat what a bizarre
question right getting pulled in there
can you I need you to tell me who you
voted for in the last election and this
is even more relevant now that we know
that last week sessions himself was
officially pulled into the investigation
by Robert Muller
this is way way way too involved with
the details of law enforcement agencies
and their staff and it's another
possible entryway into charges of
obstruction of justice so now there's a
variety of questions what will be the
next indictment because clearly there's
more indictments coming did Jeff
Sessions change his tune on some of
these issues when questioned by the
special prosecutor staff since even if
you are the Attorney General still crime
to lie to investigators in this
situation even if you're Jeff Sessions
and hopefully sessions signature lines
that he's known for I don't recall I
find the question offensive I wouldn't
be able to tell you one way or the other
off the top of my head I'm hoping that
those wouldn't fly when you're talking
to Muller's investigators although I
would I would guess if sessions thought
he could get away with it he would
probably try it's really crazy how this
is all flipped on its head right Jeff
sessions he's the Attorney General he's
the top lawyer in the country and yet
he's being questioned over this he's the
one being questioned by the people that
are sort of generally speaking in terms
of the organizational chart below
him at this time if I were Jeff Sessions
it would be occurring to me to throw
Trump totally under the bus to go to
molars investigators and say I want to
tell you everything I know come
completely clean and try to maybe get
immunity from from Muller if he thinks
that it's possible he would be
implicated although for some weird
reason Trump seems to have influence and
people seem to remain loyal to him well
I don't know when Trump was pressuring
Jeff Sessions to resign because he knew
better than to just outright fire him
yep it seemed like Sessions wanted to
stay put if he was doing that because he
believed it was the right thing it's
possible that he might realize the right
thing is to stop with the I don't
recalls and I find the question
offensive and instead say to Robert
Miller here's everything I know
I would I would like to cooperate as
Michael Flynn we now learn did and maybe
get immunity from future prosecution I
don't know but in the last 24 hours we
have learned that Jeff sessions has
already been pulled into this
investigation and that Robert Miller
wants Trump pulled into it as well if
you thought it was going to be over by
turkey day 2017 certainly it's going the
opposite direction I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show let me know what you think
about these recent developments today's
program is sponsored in part by
brilliant which is a really great unique
online service that has sort of
reinvented how people learn math and
science if you watch our show you're
probably naturally inherently curious
about how the world works and you might
be interested in something like solar
energy or computer science or philosophy
and if you want to take that knowledge
to the next level it's a great thing to
explore the brilliant platform because
you can really get acquainted with these
topics by learning hands-on how to solve
problems you work with puzzles all
designed by expert educators and
professionals and you can get started
right now by signing up for free at
brilliant org slash David Pakman and the
first 200 people who visit brilliant org
slash David Pakman will get 20% off and
annual premium membership one more time
that's brilliant org slash David Pakman